it wasn't enough that last year around a
year ago they
they put a ban on the the burka the
negoti if that wasn't bad enough
uh they they seem to think it's okay to
now try and ban the hijab
so apparently in france to be able to
wear the hijab
you need to be at least 18 years of age
toward the hijab
mothers who are the hijab cannot
accompany their children on school trips
if they're wearing the hijab so they
either don't go or they take it off
and it's just a complete violation
of human rights and religious rights
a lot of people don't know this right
because the schools don't like to teach
things that are that that
promotes anything against the western
ideology of the western view or the west
being
you know the heroes of the world uh
subhan allah
but there is actually a war and this
this war has been going on for like over
a hundred years it's crazy
against france and algeria now a lot of
people don't know this because it's not
really talked about allah and it's not
taught in schools like i mentioned
but france actually well actually what
happened it wasn't really for religious
reasons per se
but algeria mostly muslim country a lot
of muslims there
so they wanted independence algeria
wanted independence away from france and
eventually they got that
but at what cost because france
apparently didn't like that obviously
they didn't like that
not only did they massacre and murder
either hundreds of thousands or upwards
of 1.5 million algerian muslims
they actually imprisoned tortured and
raped them
just like the chinese communist party
we're hearing about today
[Music]
you shouldn't be afraid
but like you should never not be afraid
because like the moment that you say oh
well i'm not afraid
to go to hell well then you're pretty
much assuming that you're going to
heaven
and at that point like you might not do
what you should be doing in order to
like do your part in this dunya in this
world
like do your good deeds and um
earn more favor if that's even a thing
that's happening
you know we don't know for sure only
allah knows
so um they always have to be some
some level of fear that that will let
you know like hey
um i'm not guaranteed janna like this is
not guaranteed for me i don't deserve it
i need to
earn it i need to actually be the best
person that i can be
here i need to treat others the best way
possible i need to do my part in this
world
to help others and to help myself
guys and girls welcome back to the
realest podcast in the dunya
the three muslims t3m we're joined with
the three usual three muscles
he is frozen as well there we go are you
froze bro
i froze oh yeah that's crazy bro i saw
romney frozen
was fine
guys ramadan is around the corner we
have a few days
about a week left ramadan with the
angels and many other reverts first
ramadan
in history and with us and i wish all of
you have the best um
ramadan and man there's some stuff going
on in france too
do you want to get into that yeah subhan
allah so now
it wasn't enough that last year around a
year ago they they put a ban on the the
burka the night
if that wasn't bad enough uh they they
seem to think it's okay to now try and
ban the hijab
so apparently in france to be able to
wear the hijab
you need to be at least 18 years of age
toward the hijab
mothers who are the hijab cannot
accompany their children on school trips
if they're wearing the hijab so they
either don't go or they take it off
and it's just a complete violation
of human rights and religious rights and
so it's completely
completely absurd
is that a lightning bolt in the
background yeah it is only on turn on
but it's not bright enough so it looks
weird
but uh not bad but real quick so the
country that's been
having a history against muslims i know
you know i want you to go a little bit
more into that with the algeria crisis
uh france who's been you said you said
girls can't wear
a hijab until 18. yeah yeah we'll talk
about that we'll talk about that
that's crazy bro i'm pretty sure bro
wasn't it the french that were
a lot of french directors were trying to
uh promote pedophilia and normalize
pedophilia yeah
not just with government mandates and
acceptability but there's been so many
french directors that i know
that they've been trying to make movies
like cuties make them mainstream
uh and just normalize this whole thing
about you know little girls just showing
whatever
which isn't that sus to you yeah 100
um the the the director of cuties
um is a french director and this
is this is a movie or a show or whatever
that was going to be put on netflix that
everyone
was going crazy about because it
literally promotes pedophilia
it puts i think it was more specifically
a muslim girl who was wearing hijab
that takes it off of course because it's
a netflix series and if that wasn't bad
enough she ends up
going to twerk competitions and to work
with a bunch of other little girls
this isn't like 18 years old like they
make you be
18 years old to put on the hijab uh but
this is the young girls the kid
where if anyone were to go after this
kid they would be a pedophile
clearly and it's it's it's it's
disgusting it's vile and it's like all
this in the name of what
liberalism secularism where the hell you
know where is from
you know what this was the name of wrote
apparently the theme was
that muslim oppressed
little young girls need the west need
france to free them of their shackles of
you know being covered up like a like a
bag and we now need to
you know let them spread their wings and
fly and go to these twerking contests
which makes no sense
i know bro you don't have any kids guy
uh son or daughter but imagine you have
a daughter
three-year-old she's out here eating her
froot loops uh
for breakfast and she goes on netflix
and starts watching this
and you walk in bro what is going
through your head
i'll beat it think i think that says it
all bro
no i wouldn't beat it i don't know i
would i would
see you a little weird uh
you know like i i wouldn't have any
words at the moment i may
shut it up but i shut it off myself and
um
like i said i wouldn't have any words
because it's just it's ridiculous
uh subhanallah so a lot of people don't
know this
right because the schools don't like to
teach things that are that that
promotes anything against the western
ideology of the western view or the west
being
you know the heroes of the world uh
subhanallah
but there is actually a war and this
this war has been going on for like over
100 years it's crazy
against france and algeria now a lot of
people don't know this because it's not
really talked about allah and it's not
taught in schools like i mentioned
but france actually well actually what
happened it wasn't really for religious
reasons per se
but algeria mostly muslim country a lot
of muslims there
so they wanted independence algeria
wanted independence away from france and
eventually they got that
but at what cost because france
apparently didn't like that obviously
they didn't like that
not only did they massacre and murder
either hundreds of thousands or upwards
of 1.5 million algerian muslims
they actually imprisoned tortured and
raped them
just like the chinese communist party
we're hearing about today
there have been people who were a part
of the um
i forgot the acronym for it but the a
part of the the french side
who after these these people were
imprisoned
would gang rape them and violate them
and punish them i even heard one
disgusting disgusting
uh experience where a person
a person came forth and said that they
tortured me and they said i was
too disgusting to rape and they started
shoving things inside of me
may they be punished and cursed may they
be punished and cursed
we have people who come forth decades
later saying what they did admitting to
it and being fined for it
not giving some kind of death sentence
or in prison for the rest of their life
fine for it
absolutely atrocious so this was
happening
and this war has been going on for
hundreds of years i'm not saying it
currently happens i'm not saying it
doesn't allahu adam
but this is the history of france this
is what they did this is their history
of
you know what they're doing to the
muslims what they did to the muslims and
if this is the first time you're hearing
about this
that is sad this is the problem that we
actually don't know
how vile france is people think france
or paris you know eiffel tower is
beautiful no
it's actually it's actually vile two
hijabis got stabbed
in paris was it beside the eiffel tower
is like
yeah it was right by it subhanallah
beside the eiffel tower so now what do
you think eiffel tower i want you to
think the place where
two uh muslims got attacked suffolk this
is france
this is france disgusting do you guys
have anything to say
about this you know yeah i do bro matter
of fact and i think
a lot of people can agree with me when
what happened was
completely horrendous but you know what
the response was to the two
muslims hijabis that got stopped walking
with their kids
they said this is exactly a typical
response from
deeply troubled uh you know french
citizens
who have been dealing with stuff like
the the thing with the cartoons
they're saying this is just reactionary
you know we're tired of your people
you know having a problem with us making
cartoons and doing this
so this is what we're going to do that's
constituted
that's the most like why are you making
cartoons in the first place bro exactly
exactly
stupid like
i know the process that i said i'm such
an iconic person you feel the need to
draw him artistically
but why why is it what why why is it
some kind of denial of your human
rights your god-given rights your
secular given rights or liberalistic
given rights
to draw a person who you have you
probably don't even think existed
or most you hate if i had someone i
wouldn't take the liberty of drawing
them
so why is it so important for you to
draw them could it perhaps be
the fact that muslims you proclaim that
it's wrong to draw the prophet peace and
blessings be upon him
and because you know it's wrong and it
would offend us
you go out of your way to do it how is
that
some kind of declaration of freedom of
speech how is it not hate speech
intentionally doing something no one's
going to offend our our religion
and us as muslims completely idiotic you
know a lot of people ask this question
that what is even wrong with
drawing cartoons of the prophet ali was
prophets as a whole i'll give my answer
i want to hear what you guys think
there's no right answer to this but
essentially my answer
is if you're someone prophetic or you
have someone prophetic
to the to the level of of status and
value and
they're already maximally as perfect as
a human being can be know that human
beings are flawed and
you know we're imperfect but they're as
perfect as they could be and anything
you do more is just it's just going to
do less now
you're already 100 what can you do to
that to make it better you can't really
do anything
so you as a human as a creation as an
imperfect flawed being
who is not prophetic by any means you
now trying to recreate that
makes no sense i'm pretty sure that's
also why we're not allowed to
you know have pictures and paintings of
people and you know draw faces and all
that too
because we're now recreating or
attempting to recreate something which
shouldn't even be something that we
should even embark on
yeah 100 100 percent on health do you
have anything to add to that
yeah i just think that um
anytime someone is drawn sculpted
or anything like that it just leads to
idolization
it doesn't have to be just the prophet
it could be a normal human being
normal person could be an animal you
could draw an
animal or put a portrait of an animal in
this
like at some point low key is going to
be a form of idolization
and i mean bro like if we're talking
about
prophet muhammed peace be upon him and
we're going to talk about jesus peace be
upon him
uh abraham adam
jacob was jacob one of them or am i
getting that twisted with the bible
yeah okay uh but like yo like
a lot of these other prophets you don't
see them drawn
yeah 100 i mean some people try and go
out of the way to draw like jesus
yeah you don't but bro before you give
me your point i want on hell to
understand too that the cartoons and i'm
pretty sure you're aware of this
they're not cartoons that are to depict
the prophet
make fun of him yeah defame him to
slander him to make him out to be
something weird and
something that people look at and
they're like who is that and then when
they find out who they're trying to
depict they're just like they have a bad
taste in their mouth about islam
well they've done that about jesus too
romney before you go
i think the whole thing that happened
with jesus peace be upon him when they
make cartoons basically making fun of
him um you don't hear
many christians and uh catholics
backing that up or trying to like go
against it or just say
like oh this is wrong it's like that
because come on now like that religion
it pretty much teaches you to uh turn
your cheek
and to be solved
yeah i mean yeah go ahead go ahead i'm
like cutting you off too
no worries i was just gonna say and i
don't think they have a problem with
drawing jesus because
they draw jesus they have portraits and
pictures of jesus and i'm not saying
every christian is like that i'm not
but if you look at catholicism they have
statues of mother mary um
you know maryam peace be upon her and
they have
uh portrayals of jesus even though he
was very unlikely to be um
a white guy with um you know
looking the way he looked and the way
they depicted him so i don't think they
really have a problem with with
drawings the only reason is an issue for
us is because islamically
theologically it's an issue we don't
think it's it's proper for both the
reasons that you guys mentioned
because think about it especially let's
take the prophetic synonym and say
um we started drawing him because it's
not just drawings do you think someone's
allowed to
to be in a movie called muhammad and
act as if he's the prophet
because as humans i mean this is my
interpretation my understanding i'm not
a scholar
no one's going to be like fire so no
one's going to be up to that level no
one should
try and imitate the process and claim to
be like him or claim to be similar to
him
and think about it like this if someone
were to watch that movie every time they
think of the prophet muhammad who
they're going to see
they don't think of that person exactly
you think of the actor
that's not who it was and the father
even though he was a beautiful person
we have descriptions of him how he
looked even though it's good to know how
he looked across
the process and how you know beautiful
he was as a man like
what what matters more is the sunnah how
he lived
who he was the things we can actually
imitate okay his forehead was this big
and his nose was
this like it looked like this his
proportions were like that am i going to
undergo surgery
no stuff for allah but he acted away let
me also act that way sorry
right so and as angel said it starts off
let's say they were to draw the
prosthetist
it starts off as a drawing then it goes
to a statue
then it goes to household statues it
goes to a big statue in like the city's
capital
do you think people are not going to go
to that statue
and like go and start saying things like
them and look up at it
and then it becomes some kind of idol
worships at one point
and this is why the prophetic said that
um may the jews and christians be cursed
because they made the graves of the
prophets places of worship
and he made sure that his grave was not
turned into a place of worship
he was buried in the masjid which
already existed but his
his grave itself was not made into a
place of worship
because this is what our religion is
trying to protect us from
making false idols which is haram even
like in judaism in the old testament
making idols worshipping them
idolatry uh so on and so forth
about one crazy dude go ahead don't let
that know i was going to go on a
different topic so you should go
yeah before you do that i just think
it's funny that
in the christian movies you got so many
christian movies where
they got actors basically uh playing
jesus peace be upon him
like oh my god i actually i heard this
one story one of the actors
um when he was he was hit by lightning
while acting as if he was jesus
and he instead of taking that as a maybe
i shouldn't be doing this
he took it as god is trying to show me
the torment that jesus went through to
die for our sins
and i'm like stuff for a while take a
hint you got hit by lightning does it
have to happen the second time
come on man stop for a while bro that's
just
that's that's dumb that's like you know
how the people that were building the
titanic they were like oh this
this type that we're going to make this
ship so strong that even god can't sink
it
and then what what do you know happened
bro as soon as they said that what do
you know happen
now imagine they take it as oh that
actually meant that you know we were
actually not as good as we could be now
the next one will be even stronger and
then maybe god can't
like bro come on man
but let's let let's go back to france
for a second
i want to point something out because
people people are so oblivious nowadays
right uh people
like uh brother um the brother we had
the activists for the uyghurs
um arsenal brother arsene yeah
when he came on he mentioned that in in
in china they know that the chinese news
is just propaganda they know it
but we don't know that when we hear
things about friends and we hear
something we don't
think about the implications of it why
are they doing that what outcome could
it have
it's just they're doing it right so
let's think about it
there previously was no legal age of
consent for sex
so you can have a young girl 14 15 who
says i'm ready to have sex
and recently i heard that the age of
consent is 15.
so you can have a 15 year old girl in
france
who says i'm ready to have sex
unprotected unprotected if i want
i'm ready to have sex and on top of that
you can have sex you can you can have
incest right you can commit an act of
incest
as long as you're both over the age of
18 it's legal it's fine
so you can be 18 years old and decide i
want to have incest you can be
15 years old a 15 year old girl and say
i want to have sex
but you need to be 18 years old to say i
want to wear a scarf
that covers my hair how on earth
somebody i'll give you a million a
million tries
give me one justifiable reason as to why
that's okay
even by liberalistic um a liberalistic
standpoint even from a secular
standpoint
because secular is the division from
religion and state
that doesn't mean the people can't be
religious it's just it won't be a law
but now you're doing anti-islamic
anti-religious laws
this is a huge problem and i was
thinking about it
why on earth would they make the legal
issue with the hijab 18 you have to be
an adult
i was thinking about it and i want you
guys to think about it like this
18 years is more than enough time
to educate people into thinking that
hijab is bad
so by the time they're 18 they don't
even want to wear anymore 18 years is
enough time of being in school
in the secular school system being
taught very specific things
being pushed on this propaganda so when
you get to the point where you're 18 you
don't even have your islamic values
and it's already illegal uh previously i
wasn't wearing until 18 i'm not i'm not
going to aware
it's bad anyways suffolk okay i think
even 12 years is enough
to condition someone but 18 is more than
enough time yeah
yeah it's and on top of that
um and you this just adds to how badly
they want to
um put it in people's heads that hijab
is not normal
not only did they ban the burqa but
they're trying to ban it in young girls
so that the next generation when they're
in school they don't see it even from
the parents on field trips
why would they include something like
that you you can be an adult and decide
to wear hijab but you can't be around
kids during a field trip why
not even kids your own kid yeah yeah for
what for protection
no it's because they don't want these
kids to see a woman wearing hijab and
get any ideas
they don't even want to see a muslim
that's crazy yeah nice you're going to
be saying you you can't have a beard
suffer you can't have a beard this is a
part of your religion may allah protect
them from that
i mean it's a complete agenda and people
are missing this
it is a complete agenda against islam
this is not okay they're gonna fail
i promise you i promise you they're
going to fail
many people have tried before many
people have failed before
there's just going to be another a group
of people on a long list of people who
failed
but they're trying and this is a big
problem because now as muslims we have
to deal with it we have to stand against
it but it's finally i know i went on a
rant there somewhere
i'm gonna take a break now what do you
guys uh what do you guys think
oh no no bro i could sense that you want
to say something
i don't think man i'm just kind of tired
of it bro is it hold up is it
is it me or did um did fire's video like
scrunch up
i think it's you he's fine on my screen
oh you are scrunched in my screen bro
you look
like a toothpick right now take a
screenshot so we can put it on
[Music]
um
sorry what were you saying i'm just
saying bro like how much longer
is is uh are we just going to turn the
other cheek
even though we're not turning the other
cheek but it's like what can we do
i want that's what i want you to get
into after uh you know you can like
recollect and gather some more
thoughts because you look at this whole
bias that there always was you think
they're gonna hire
um a guy that looks like a muslim like
overtly
on average more than a guy that doesn't
in france no
right so naturally you're saying oh what
are they gonna do next band the
uh band the beard he's the thing they
don't have to ban the beard for people
to just wake up as a muslim
and wonder should i shave my beard
before this job interview
what if i don't even get it so naturally
there's this inclination or dissonance
within
that i can't look like how i want to
look and there shouldn't be a problem
with that but
now there is but it's like i think
you're right the step further is going
to be a whole
legal ramification for that which
they've already done with hijab
i think that the cab's already been
banned since a year or two ago right
um
the thoughts people must be going
through uh just living in france
things like should i look muslim should
i act muslim uh
subhanallah yeah should i should i even
cover up before i walk near the eiffel
tower or will i get stabbed
like those real question is why is
anyone living in france
like why are muslims living in france if
they see how it is over there
a lot i don't think i don't think people
are really encouraged to move there now
actually i remember talking to a guy
about a year ago
um on instagram about this um i don't
think he like he talked about it but
he's a bit iffy about it now
um i think it's more so people who live
there and their
generations before them lived there and
on and so forth
um especially with the crisis like with
algeria and stuff if any algerians ended
up living
in france even though the france hates
them i believe
yeah american i was shopping up with him
one day he was telling me how most
people that work in france
i think they legally have a property in
germany
because there's like a border between
france and germany and what they do is
france is really good
pay so what these people do is they keep
that salary
and when it comes to filing taxes they
just come you know to the border
come to germany because they file german
taxes which is significantly lower
than in france but germany doesn't have
that good pay compared to france
so it gives you another reason for
people living in france with their
stupid high taxes like why am i even
living here
i personally don't know anyone in my
family living in france
um and i have people worldwide
everywhere uh
so again this whole thing about boycott
friends boycott china
um it all starts with knowledge and
seeking and understanding that it's been
going on for
decades centuries how many muslims did
you do do you think
you estimate that they slayed in algeria
so the thing is algeria claimed 1.5
million lives
but each side is going to claim a
different number french was saying i
think
10 like tens of thousands or like maybe
100 000 or something
even if they claimed hundreds of
thousands what was their agenda what was
their
the thing that they came out for their
intention that they publicized
like the reason they went to war or
um i think honestly just because they uh
algeria wanted independence to be like
an independent uh
nation by themselves uh
in france you know went against that and
they actually they would write
on i saw a picture once i i don't know
where it was i think it was in a
whatsapp group
it was written in french on one of the
bridges this is where we drowned
algerians
this is how much hatred they had towards
them
there's no difference between china and
france honestly
honestly i hate to say it doesn't seem
like there's much of a difference it
really does not seem like there's much
of a difference one is fueled more by
this uh secularist ideology um
that's turned more anti-religious rather
than just separating it from state
and and china seems to be more just
communist which is like
religion is not allowed it's not even
communist if if uh you know based on
what brother arsene said right
their their intentions are now just just
control just power
if you think about it the world so much
depends on china
and goods and services it's insane bro
yeah it's actually kind of scary when
you it's
a rabbit hole uh i urge any of you if
you have free time go into it but
literally if you didn't own anything
from china
you you cannot imagine what your house
would look like what your room would
look like
yeah it's crazy bro i mean
[Music]
our room is pretty minimal so i think
you look the same way it does now
then bro maybe half your your uh your
whole wardrobe would be out bro
my whole wardrobe black pretty much
you said black yes it don't matter about
the color bro
you think china doesn't make black
clothes no they're
they don't do black clothes what do they
do then
the other called this marshall bro
you gotta really talk about this guy
listen astrophysics
you know about it listen i do think that
again i i don't know why people even
living in france like i heard france
sucks
i heard the only thing that's like cool
about it is maybe the eiffel tower and
then everything else is just
trash it's like if you're trying to move
from like wherever you're living
um you would think you would go
somewhere else like
costa rica thailand um
indonesia somewhere there like
so many better places that yeah you'd
have to learn a different language but
you go to france you gotta learn a
different language too
yeah i don't see the appeal myself um
but matter of fact is there are muslims
there and they're suffering
um again i don't know why uh anyone want
to live there
but uh yo tell me tell me if i'm the
only one that can relate to this
maybe romney can a lot of the viewers
definitely will angel might not because
he's in the states
but growing up in canada we were forced
to learn french
as a language from grade four it is
forest bro from grade four
to grade nine and not only that if you
take it after that
and you you take it in university and
you stay uh
you know fluent in french then there's
there's literally a bias like
you're you're more likely to get a job
where it literally makes no sense bro
you bro i can't even call the government
to you know
inquire about some taxes without them
literally saying some
long line in french and then being like
in english
press one bro why should i even hear
that i'm pretty sure nobody
here has a problem with english and
understanding english
but for this little bit they're hyper
you know imposing this
yeah i mean canada was founded by the
french
yeah um and what year bro
i don't know but i know that it's um
and it pretty much all french 1867
um so much to the point where we have a
province of
quebec i'm pretty sure they wanted to
just uh you know leave
and not you know become a part of and
stay a part of canada
uh but that didn't really work out in
their favor so now i don't know maybe
canada feels bad and did that's why
they're trying to teach kids french for
most
yeah learning french was always such a
pain uh
it was honestly the most annoying thing
but i do have friends who uh
who live in in montreal and like uh
in like surrounding areas that speak
french very importantly
they always speak english just as
fluently i know yo tell me this i can't
be the only one
that initially when i heard about the
whole thing with lil nas
ain't he gay yeah he's gay bro yes
he didn't come from a two-parent
household yes
he's pole dancing in videos and yes
there should be every reason
we find himself and question him but
when i first found out about the whole
thing about
uh i think the the shoes that he was
collabing with nike and and their uh
if he puts real human blood in it and
it's supposed to be like some satanic
thing
because the the music video i didn't
really watch it but apparently he was
just literally giving
satan a lap dance that's what the music
video was
i'm just like bro are these guys running
out of like content
material ideas you're resorting to
writing bible verses
in the heels in the heel drop and it's
this blood
themed satanic shoe with real blood
you're now here
literally pole dancing and giving satan
a lap dance because
there's nothing else to rap about
let me just do that for attention
to be honest it's like in mma um
a lot of the uh the top fighters that
are there
because of the clout they had to like do
something extra
in order to get that clout like conor
mcgregor supposedly he wasn't
he wasn't as uh cocky as you'd see him
and obviously he's not as cocky anymore
because he's been humble
big time but um
[Music]
shoot bro like look at uh kobe covington
some of y'all might not know him some of
y'all might but this man
like nobody wanted to hear anything from
him nobody wants to see his fights
because
they said it was boring and he literally
had to become
a racist individual in order to start
getting attention from people
like is he racist probably not but he's
doing it for
the attention and for the money so i
guess you say that he's
kind of selling his soul if
it's this guy but do you know more about
that uh ramyan no
but what actually went down with the
shoes and the collab um
i heard a few different things i heard
that nike denied being a part of it and
then
they might be suing him but i don't i
don't like does he really need to do it
for publicity
isn't he like already a really big
artist he's made a few hits already
people are already listening to his
music
um if
what's up bro once someone is a clout
head
they're going to stay cloud head are you
going to keep trying to get more and
more clout
that's fair that's fair um from an
islamic perspective
when a person sells their souls to the
devil
and starts you know partaking in these
these haram actions something that is
literally an
act of kufur takes you like it's
basically a guaranteed ticket to hell
unless they they turn from that when
somebody does something like that
the devil has them do a series of vile
things disgusting things to uh to kind
of keep up
with everything and we heard a story
once about i believe
a jewish rabbi from the time of the
children of israel who
was like one of the greatest scholars of
their time like he was an amazing guy
he was an amazing guy and um these three
brothers
asked him to take care of their little
sister when they went out to travel or
for war or something like that
and slowly slowly over time he got worse
and worse with her
like he first he would leave the food at
the door then he'd start bringing it in
then he would sit and talk with her and
then eventually it became haram
she got pregnant he ended up killing her
and the baby
burying her then the three brothers when
they got back
he said that she'd die from some disease
and then
the brothers saw a dream that
the burial site they were shown as fake
and the real burial is somewhere else
and they went they dug it up and they
saw that
there's their sister and this baby there
so then they go and they they question
the guy he gets taken in
and then shaytan appears to him and he's
like i'm shaytaan
i put you in the situation and i'm the
only one who can get you out
if you pray to me now if you worship me
and pray to me now i'll get you out of
this
he he prayed to shaytan he prayed to
satan
satan left him and the man was killed
the last act he did was worshipping
satan literally before he died
damn i don't know
bro see i'm i'm just going to add on to
what you said
because um people who do
get into all this uh satanic stuff from
what i heard
all right this is just from what i heard
um
they do some pretty questionable things
and it's like it's like they're getting
all these things
you they you just some people say it's
like blessings but they're not really
blessed it's just material things
they're getting the success and all that
and that's like okay now
you've gotten all this now you have to
do this you have to do something that's
humiliating
and like if you look at all almost all
the the mainstream
rappers like they've all done something
that's like
pretty damn humiliating
so i was like seeing lil knox do
something like this
i it it doesn't surprise me
to be honest y'all y'all heard about uh
the whole
anal swabs of the kova testing in china
what the hell
well please tell me you've heard about
this i have not
literally the whole nasal swab alone
is weird that's my opinion because
you shoving this yay big
you know swab up your nose to test if
you have covered
when there's just as accurate uh testing
done in a lot of emirates in uae
where they do this pin prick in your
fingertip which literally in a
matter of seconds can give you the
result too um
not seconds a couple seconds to do the
thing a couple hours gives you the
result
way better way more efficient way safer
too
um but instead they want to do this nose
thing that i already found weird
the fact that they're also charging you
know upwards of 100 plus dollars in
canada do that i also find that weird
um then using that to say you need this
to go
and fly i was kind of like okay where do
you draw the line you know because
now we need to have that so many people
are not going to find out just to not
have that experience
i personally wouldn't care but then they
took it a step further and they said
if you do leave canada you can't now
come back
unless you want to pay this 2 000 per
person thing to quarantine at a hotel
bro why can't i continue on my house
this makes no sense
but ladies and gentlemen china
implemented this thing called the anal
swab which is you take the exact thing
that they're gonna put in your nose
spread your cheeks and just take it in
bro they could take every inch
and what happened was they did this to
joe biden's crew
when they went to china recently and you
know what they said after that
very quick after that that oh uh medical
uh you know clinical evidence has shown
that that actually wasn't necessary
we could have just stuck to the nose
thing they literally just implemented
for that period of time
got that done just to humiliate them bro
because
think about it bro trump has been saying
china virus into that of time itself bro
and now you got uh you know biden who's
going to be
a simp and a half who's going to go to
china and bro china just literally just
stuck it to them bro
see i didn't hear about the the anal spa
but i didn't hear about the thumb and
the booty hole
y'all heard about that one yo rami left
that sound you made is gonna be
definitely uh
a highlight romney bro so disgusting he
left
i need a minute i needed a minister i
don't know about disgusting bro i think
you made him feel a little uh
funny aroused
stuff for a while um
i don't want to regret asking but what
are you talking about
it's a new test
can't tell if you're joking or not no
he's for real bro
my god what is it why why yeah
it's um yeah they just they
stick dumb keyboard
listen i've never done it i can't tell
you any details
all right you're gonna have to do it
yourself in order to find out
or is it where is it you don't want to
tell us because you've done it now you
don't want to tell us you've done it
nope it's okay bro
if it's not a if it's not a thumb it's
another finger it's okay bro you can
tell us too
listen i have not done it my only thing
is bro you know when uh you go to the
doctor and they do the physical test to
test like your prostate
exam and all that that's like that's
already like whatever bro
you know but an anal swab bro to check
if you have
covid come on bro that's my stuff
come on bro damn what is the world
coming to though like
i remember talking about so many
treacherous things in this episode
yeah prostate exam being the worst
listen on a side note just talking about
prostate exams i remember
when i went to get a prostate exam and i
was in
11th grade and i was in the doctor's
office
and the doctor literally like put on
these gloves and before he put on the
gloves
like i looked over and like the little
box on the table said extra large
oh bro i think i started crying bro
i think i started crying my mom was
right next to me and then he asked my
mom
is it oh do you want to be in here and
she's like yeah and he looked at music
she doesn't have to be in here i was
like no no no please like i need her in
you
bro they turned me to my side the worst
experience i've ever said in my life
just for a prostate exam why why do you
have to do that
i think little knowledge would uh beg
otherwise
what the hell did this episode come to i
don't know but it just
it just it just goes to show the state
of the world that if somebody asked us
a couple months ago a couple years ago
uh this is all gonna be
one episode of one podcast talking about
current affairs
globally um locally
whatever you want to call it just in the
world nobody would be like i bro
100 i agree people would think this is a
joke people would think this is like
some like
comedy skit in actuality bro this is
literally the state of the world today
yo so we got a few minutes left i think
what we should do
for the end of this episode is leave
people
with some kind of action plan something
that they can do on their part
whether that be make dua for the people
in france right now or whether that be
uh maybe donating to a certain
link or someone who's trying to do
something about that
situation right now we could definitely
find that but i think that'd be best
yeah first and foremost share this video
people need to know about this
uh secondly uh it would be the same
strategy
for the uyghur muslims which i encourage
all of you go watch the episode and
share that as well
you have to share the episode make your
own uh videos
write-ups articles whatever blog posts
about it share the news
let people know let them share the news
reach out to the politicians the mps or
whoever has some kind of political power
and uh sign the petitions uh find the
organizations and donate
and just do whatever you can as an
individual to stand up against us even
if it's just making dua as brother angel
said
or sharing the video to let people know
that these atrocious things are going on
in the world yes in the 21st century the
amazing amazing time period we live in
with all this freedom and liberation for
everybody
yes people are being masqueraded in
prison tortured raped
yes this is happening today and you yes
you
need to share this video and let people
know you need to make your own video
you need to share this knowledge with
the world so that insha allah
muslims can stop being persecuted around
the world
i mean i mean
all right guys um
if you made it this far go ahead and
comment
hashtag lunas
and like prince of persia said
do your part you can put up a post
you can put up a video um do
something all right because you know you
can do
something we all know we can do
something so try to figure out what is
that something that you can do
and if really all that you can do is
make do other
that's more than enough but if you have
the means to do something else then
you should probably do it because you
don't want to be
you know not not in the fear-mongering
but on the day of judgment
you don't want to be questioned be like
yo you could have done this
could have done that why don't you do
that and you were you're just going to
be there
like nah so
again not fear-mongering just being
honest with y'all
but with that being said let's close
this video out
if i had anything else to add or nothing
man if you're trying to if you're trying
to go through ramadan
not come out looking like a pig and
or you're trying to come out of ramadan
not trying to look like you lost all
your gains
you already know who to hit up bro hit
me up on instagram
ramadan coaching me meal plan
workouts i got a whole ramadan guide
just to help you
you know stay in shape not really let it
get in the way
you're trying to get some poetry you're
trying to you try you're either reverb
or uh you know you're you're not a
reaver but you want to help reverse hit
up robbie bro
you want to you know take your take your
you know
thumb in the in the booty whole game to
the next
hit up on her bro i know i know he
didn't get his instagram there because
he feels a little weird about these
things but
just get it done man come on you see the
black bro you know he's certified
what is he said about that i don't know
bro but he's certified
dm all right i'll give you the
instruction
[Music]
got the extra large gloves please don't
forget
them yeah i remember fired workout plan
man actually i looked really good in
that time period mashallah when he hit
me up
um he had good prices alhamdulillah and
i was looking pretty good
so um definitely i can vouch and say it
is a good program
uh don't look at me now i fell off
myself so like don't use that as a
comparison but back then i think you
fell out boy but your beard glowed the
hell up bro
yeah that view is looking nice
but yeah for real bro uh jessica okay
bro i appreciate it
um it's what i'm it's literally what i'm
here for just to help you guys and
it's not gonna be typical cookie cutter
advice it's not gonna be stuff like
you know high carb low fat or low low
fat
uh or low carb high fat it's not gonna
be anything like that it's not gonna be
something like uh
just uh eat this eat that we're not
gonna do a bulk we're not gonna do a cut
it's gonna be doing both at the same
time losing fat gaining muscles during
ramadan
and implementing suhoor and iftar
strategically
yeah if you made it this far do hashtag
little loss like anno said hashtag
boycott france
and if you made it this far too hashtag
boycott shaytan if you put all three
you will be entered into uh one in
50 000 chance of winning a one-on-one
consult
uh free bootyhole console with uh this
guy right here
that is it bro and with that being said
rami hand it off
all right with that being said allah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hmm